じゃあ
やっぱり金髪いいなぁ
を裂傷金髪でいいああお前は本当にそう思っているのか誰だお前は俺はもう一人の初め
お前の心の闇の部分を打つます
これが1人の弾み治療ん
ていません
何が痛いしたなう
本当に心から金髪がいいと思っているからだ
俺は誰にどう思われようが関係ないああ
目指すために金髪にしたんが本当に本当にそう思ってるかなっ
[音楽]
何でそう思うお前はいろんな人からじゃない
この y 前のほうが良かったと言われて
実は気にしてるんだろうそう
そんなこと自分に正直になれお前は自分の金髪を気に入っているが周りのイメージも口
にしている
銀髪なんてやめちまえ違う
[音楽]
を決めたんん
先発で生きていくということを
もう後戻りはできない
うたかけた身の毛だぞそんなものを消してどーするー
古神して楽になれないっ
これは
俺は自分のしたいようにある
その決めたんだ俺は先行の初め
チン発で行くぞ超式を考えるぞ
音ぞ悪夢髪が一番がいい
夏を好きだって
この俺がぶっ壊す金髪は year グローバー木場 the
フロリダでバーサーカー黒神だ k パーサー
蜘蛛神だ
金髪クライアン原発なぁ黒がり屋チェーン
grown 者
me
jump tour
カラーチェンジャー
光の初めと闇の初めの戦いは半世紀にもわたったん
そしてお互いを認め合った時シーンの初めの姿がそこにはあったん
[音楽]
ブーバーある
あああああ
はぁ